all right the supreme court confirmation
fight officially underway
democrats continuing to dodge a key
question will they in fact pack the high
court
if joe biden wins in november will we
have 11 supreme court justices
instead of answering though they're now
accusing republicans and they put that
in bold in the prompter it means a lot
of trying to do it we shouldn't be
having this hearing
with two members of the committee
infected with kovid
it's rushed it constitutes court packing
and her views are too extreme to qualify
her to serve on this court
so this idea that democrats are packing
the court they've already done it we're
not going to fall into the trap of
debating that now
after what they've done the only court
packing
going on right now that's going on with
republicans
packing the court now it's not
constitutional what they're doing
right um they have a talking point going
and if you thought joe biden would
finally tell us where he stands on court
backing
think again sir i've got to ask you
about packing the courts
this is the number one thing that i've
been asked about from viewers well
you've been asked by the viewers who are
probably republicans who don't want me
continuing to talk about what they're
doing to the court right now
well sir don't the voters deserve to
know
right they don't absolutely we have to
elect him to find out what exactly he's
going to do
uh degan i was surprised because this
went off the rails this weekend
they all had the same talking points
chris coons
joe biden schumer they're all said
they're packing the court by jamming
uh amy uh coney barrett in and for what
they did in the lower courts
no one's buying it well they believe the
american people are stupid enough to buy
them trying to change the definition of
packing the court
to cover for joe biden who can't answer
the question
because he's owned by the left it's the
classic
tisk tisk finger wagging at the american
people
as if we don't know what court packing
is and
down south we say this don't spit in my
face and tell me it's raining we know
the difference right they want to they
want to subvert the constitution and add
justices to the court
so they can continue to make it their
legislator legislature
so i was watching your show at two
o'clock and i thought senator chris
coons was trying to amend what he was
saying over the weekend
because he knows we're not buying
packing the court and packing the court
we know what it meant
his colleague senator ben sasse of
nebraska pointed out that that was kind
of orwellian and that
you're when you're replacing people on
the court
because there's a vacancy that is not
court packing court packing is adding
members of the supreme court the other
thing i played for coons who is a biden
surrogate
is that in 1983 joe biden when he was on
the judiciary committee said that court
packing
even though it's my segment we have that
stat so you have that much power we can
hear it all right great let's look
president roosevelt clearly had the
right to send to the united states
senate the united states congress a
proposal to pack the court
it was totally within his right to do
that he violated no law
he was legalistically absolutely correct
but it was a bonehead idea it was a
terrible terrible mistake to make has
become less boneheaded in 2020
that's what i asked and he said well he
does have a way with words but the thing
is is that they're just not answering it
i think that's a bad thing i think the
americans do deserve to know before they
go
but i also don't think that the election
really hangs on this issue i do want to
point out one thing about the quorum
republican for the amy coney barrett
hearing republicans are telling me they
do not anticipate having a problem
getting a quorum and in fact remember
the way that
kavanaugh was treated that then led to
the midterms i was about a month before
the midterms
the republicans added seats in the
senate majority and now they have a
little bit of a cushion like 12 to 10
right
i thought you needed democrats presence
well i think that they i think that
they're anticipating
that they have they must know that there
are a couple of democrats who are
going to be okay jesse tell me if i'm
overreacting i believe that if joe biden
is able to get elected and not tell us
what he's going to do
nobody's going to tell us what they're
going to do they're just going to go out
present themselves give a few speeches
we're not going to get anything of
substance i think this could be the
beginning of the end of having any
substance
in any presidential presidential
campaign i don't think you're
overreacting brian
on this many other things you react to
like in the green room
running around like a scared child i was
a little nervous
you looked a little nervous yeah you're
a little close to me yeah on the he's
getting killed on the court packing
question
and it's a self-inflicted wound i i
would just say we're not going to pack
the court right
he wouldn't actually get hurt by that
that much by saying that
he's actually getting more hurt by not
answering the question
and on the other thing about the court
packing answer
they've had three weeks to come up with
an answer and the democrats came up with
the answer
uh uh-uh you are i mean how bad is that
that is their answer and then they say
it's not constitutional
they can't point to one thing in the
constitution
that prohibits it from being
constitutional and that's when you know
it's not jesse it's not that it's a hard
question juan
they're going to do it if they get it
the filibusters
out they do a simple majority and they
add two justices
that's why he doesn't want to answer it
even though he doesn't he necessarily
knows it's not good for the country
it's good for the party they're gonna do
it if they get the senate in the white
house
i love it that you're speaking for joe
biden i think this is really interesting
on the whole i think this is like early
halloween oh my gosh what's coming the
far left they're going to pack the court
look well this has not been discussed
they didn't put it out i think you have
one or two on the far left who said
you know the republicans have been so
abusive of this process blocking merrick
garland
for more than 400 days and now with 20
days left
before an election with americans
already voting they're trying to force
through a nominee of their life
so you don't think so hang on so you ask
the question let me answer okay so i'm
saying to you
this is an abusive process and they
haven't necessarily discussed
exactly how does the other party deal
with the fact that one party is willing
to derail a system
and to satisfy their own needs now
today argument put forward by i think it
was ted cruz
who said well this is different look at
the history
when one party controls the white house
and the senate
this is what goes on but that's not
constitutional no no but
under that argument what you would get
brian what you would get
is that you would never have a supreme
court nominee unless you had the same
party controlling the house and the
senate
no packing is what you're talking i'm
saying stacking and packing are
different
okay this idea about adding additional
justices to the court
is not new and in fact it is written in
a letter
authored by sheldon whitehouse maisie
hirono kirsten gillibrand
dick durbin and richard blumenthal
threatening to
quote restructure the court which is
exactly what they were threatening to do
if the justices took up the second
amendment rights case
in new york they threatened them then
and that's why people know what they're
up to
now every time you bring it up they
change it to well this isn't right to be
doing this with barrett this is two
separate questions
which it could be another segment and
the fact that i went to a single means i
should probably just read the t's out